[Music]
all right boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host
Donald sake and very excited to be
talking about future cities we have
Sheridan Tatsuno joining us on the show
hello well hi there and thank you very
much for the invitation today
we're super excited to host you Sheridan
for those who don't know Sheridan's
background he's co-founder of one
reality which creates VR models of
sustainable cities they are currently
operating in Sweden having built models
for Copenhagen Stockholm luned and Malmo
and the links in the bio to one reality
comm check that out as well as
Sheridan's book link and the Silicon
Valley global network link and the one
reality VR demos Facebook group so go
and check those out everyone let's jump
into things with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world well right now we have a climate
crisis on our front door and we have
less I think less than 10 years to stop
it and if we don't its runaway and we
will pay dearly our children in
grandchildren so we have a real one of
the first times in history to make a
significant difference and it's gonna
require everybody not just one one
company or one country everybody's got
to be pulling together what are some of
the best ways that we can pull together
for the climate future that we desire
well I think right off the bat you know
you can do it every day do shopping when
you buy things think about it do I
really need this am i buying from a
company that recycles or do they
distress it right like plastics do I
even need plastic can i buy
biodegradable right what types of
companies - I support because remember
purchases determine stock value prices
and if a million people decide tomorrow
not to buy the stock prices in sales are
going to reflect it immediately so uncon
tried to call popular opinion shoppers
can literally sink a company
in one week ok so then do we have all
these different options that we can do
every single day so our dollar is the
way that we hurt our behaviors is
immediately yeah yeah effects the global
future right yeah okay so that's a big
one
that's a big one um okay and this is
again one of the most pressing times for
us to come together to take on to tackle
the fire that's in our house right right
now our disconnection from nature from
what sustains us and the way that were
contributing to the planet that anthropo
seen let's do your journey Sheridan so
you're born in San Jose
your grandparents came from Japan in
1893 very long time ago
you spent most of your life in the Bay
Area spent some time overseas see just
about who you were as a kid growing up
how you got interested in the fields
that you're into now when I grew up
there was no Silicon Valley it was all
orchards Sal was lucky to watch after
NASA went to the moon
the explosion if you'd asked me back
when I was like a kid what the future is
I said automated farms I and I would
have totally missed what happened so one
thing I learned is humility you cannot
predict a future because things happen
and government can play a major role so
that's one thing I learned I was very
interested the reason I got in urban
planning is I was in Caracas Venezuela
for five year be a program when I was at
Yale undergrad and the children were
dying coming in at this food co-op and I
said why they dine it was a dysentery
dirty water and I said because I'd never
seen children die and I grew up with why
I'm saying and it was really upsetting
for me when you're young so I said how
do we stop it so we put in sewer sweep
all the guys in the slum there I was
living in a slum we all pitch together
the city wouldn't help us they lent us
equipment tubes so we over a couple of
weekends we put in a sewer and ran the
sewage over cover it up put a park there
basketball courts a nice place on all
that and their children stopped dying
and I said to myself gee city planning
can save lives
that's why I got into it yeah whoa
in in so it's sometimes it's something
like the quality of water then it's
causing sicknesses right and how can a
turbine planning give us the example
that you were when when how did what you
did end up increasing the health of the
kids well I mean in Venezuela when I was
there 50% of there were of well there's
a 50% mortality rate among babies okay
that's pretty high yeah and in the slums
and reasonably are playing around in the
dirty water and it would get amoebic
dysentery and if you know anything but
this very year balls run and can't stop
and you die from dehydration you can't
keep the food or water and so the kids
literally emaciate look like skeletons
and dying and it's pretty it is very
depressing to watch that in the
community you could see them dying in
front of you so the number one rule and
then you Bill Gates talks about it in in
developing nations is provide fresh
water and sanitation just doing that
you'll save huge numbers of lives
because the problem when you have all
the dirty water all the Flies and
everything in there and then it infects
and the flies line on the food and you
get sick and it's so just and you try to
pump people with antibiotics but it
doesn't work because the flies were
still there so the number one rule in
all urban plan is eliminate the open
sewers by creating sanitation you know
in this we had chemically treated but
the begin to get the cities to invest in
you know sanitation plants like we have
you know in u.s. no swear see first of
all get rid of all the dirty water yeah
and in recycler greywater which it gives
for planting parks and farms and things
like that and then the other part of the
second part of that is providing fresh
water so a lot of that you can take
great water and now there's all these
new companies to infiltration so they
can filter it using your solar power to
power these things and then you get pure
fresh water so right now these people
spend half today going to these wells so
polluted
to get water so ideally you could just
have all this gray water or just local
water run it through filtration and then
you get pure water right off the bat
you'll save all these lines because
they're not gonna get sick right now
they're drinking all this faeces
polluted water I mean it's disgusting
and I I know if every I think to
understand you have to really go to a
slum in any one of these countries so
even we have them here with it but it's
really depressing to watch and it's you
know they're billions of people like
that and so that's the number one we're
right off the bat now the flip side
obviously is that when you save a lot of
lives you've got a huge population
explosion so the second half the
equation and this is probably the most
important is that we're going to go from
what 7 billion to maybe 12 bill 11
billion people over the next hundred
years
we can't even sustain them now that's
definitely not what the u.s. lifestyle
so we have to reduce the population but
how do you do that without forests like
you know one-child policy in China so
one of the fastest way the UN
recommended oh 10 15 years ago is
educate girls and woman that's the
fastest way to reduce family size and
the reason is very simple is that woman
who are educated girls are educated have
a future they have a career they're too
busy studying and they don't want
children because it's a distraction so
what happens is and it's happening
worldwide now in different countries
like India and even the Middle East said
you'll see families with 12 kids going
down to like three or four so if we just
educate girls and woman will solve
probably's I'll say it maybe half the
problems right off the bat and the good
part is we have all these educated woman
so think about it you have all these
girls and woman and we're not talking or
brain power because they're not educated
enough so instead of men trying to solve
the problem we have the whole world yeah
smart woman and girls solving the
problems and trust me woman and girls
are much closer to families health care
education
everything so it's probably I would
argue that woman will probably come
perfect 80% of the solutions to
everything 80 percent not 20 half
because you know unlike with my family
or in the slums the mothers and the
daughters the grandmother always worry
about the children's health and
education the sanitation the water the
shopping everything the housing
everything so if you don't have the
woman who are intelligent and educated
then you're not you really working with
not even half the brain one-third of the
brain or less and that's what we've been
doing for the last well millennia so
that's I would argue that if I were to
say anything that you can do is like
support women's and girls education and
not get into this whole birth control
issue I don't think that's an issue I
think let because what happens is when
you educate people they automatically
decide to have on the smaller families
but it's their choice yeah yeah and it's
so it's that's what I would do number
one and there's not enough discussion
about that but let's get back to basics
which is let's hit on those two things
quick on will just that first it
requires a very deep level of empathy to
dive into what it's like living behind
the eyes of people that don't have
access to clean water yes in that
struggle with up to 50% more child
mortality rates that's crazy and living
in slums these types of things is very
important to to realize that this is us
this is a reflective sisters around the
world and the way that we behave on
trying to solve the impressing
challenges is just like if it was a roll
of the dice where we're born yes so it's
very important for us to care about this
and address it and it's things like
urban planning things like preventing
sewage systems from being right there in
middle of our water systems so where
where as in the United States of so many
places where we grow up and they develop
the world it's it's it's now become
something that we take for granted the
fact that the sewage systems are
separate the water plant the recycling
of the grey water all these types of
things that's very well set and then the
other aspect is this has been said a
couple times now but it's it is very
important that when you do educate women
and girls that are growing up I think
like you said could it be that 80% of
the massive challenges and solutions
will be overcome and provided by women
that are being creative in the world and
I agree that there's a deep connection
to other humans to the care for children
to the care for our planet that women
help me dive deeper into those were very
good points and so um okay so that was
you know those were your aha moments in
Caracas and okay okay and then then when
you came bit like you were giving us
this example like it's orchards in
Silicon Valley right like the even that
in itself is like now we're like tech
everywhere $5,000 a month rent right you
know so this is completely different in
Solem what have you seen what the
evolution you did construction and urban
planning in the 70s so yes it did meet
well Silicon Valley was called the
valley of the heart's content it was a
beautiful place orchards clean water
clean air it was really paradise it was
really you know a small town San Jose
and a hundred thousand people no
highways no freeways 880 280 did not
exist 101 was a two-lane road had just
went of four-lane two hours to get San
Cisco stopped by it still takes two
hours but traffic jam now but so it's
like living in Kansas or Missouri in a
small town and so when I go through the
Midwest or into the valley Central
Valley and meet these small town people
it's like time travel for me all that
Santa's it was just like that when I was
a kid so I have a very easy time
relating to the Midwest people because
they're very modest the community focus
for
hard-working hands on the ground boots
on the ground modest people hard-working
really a solid and it was like Santa say
when I was a child and one of the things
that people don't talk about is that one
other reason myself and I succeeded is
we had a lot of vets coming back from
World War two and they didn't want to go
back to their home so they stayed here
and then after the Vietnam War Morris
they and many of these vets were from
the Midwest and farmers kids okay and if
you look at nobody's really study as
many of the engineers were farm boys
they went to the farm colleges like
Illinois University Illinois Missouri
you know and then he went and fought and
it came back and they go gee you know I
can get a job here because they're
looking for engineers so when I was a
child I remember meeting them we'd have
these block parties you know like
because the inventor and you know garage
famous garages right and then one thing
that people will talk about it was when
we got to the moon in 1969 first thing
the NASA did laid off everybody so the
unemployment rate when among engineers I
heard was 35% Silicon Valley in 1970 it
was like total disaster and we had a
recession so you couldn't get a job so
either he left town or you just did your
own stuff and the only companies in town
were chip companies AMD National Intel
who created the chips for the moon
missions right in Vietnam so I remember
when I was a kid you'd see all these
guys like hacking away and stuff in
their garages then that's Silicon Valley
because they got laid off basically and
they were farm boys with hands on yeah
and so one of the things that the
difference between now is now it's all
money game highly-educated computer
science PhDs Cal Stanford all this back
then it was more IRA members more modest
like University of Missouri Illinois
farm boys who are really good working at
their hands family friends helping each
other out
it was a totally different vibe that
family values were so present in the
earlier formative years it was more like
being in the Midwest today interesting
yeah correct
but high tech so if you were to marry
Kansas would with Silicon Valley that's
what it was like yeah you can look at
the word clouds of what is in rent
people's like Twitter profiles and in
Silicon Valley it's all like product
design Facebook Google in Kansas and
other place around the world in the
Midwest it's like family love France
that's right yeah and then so it was
like yeah of course you're gonna help
your friends out you know we're all
doing it together and then have picnics
and parties and and that's where the the
Silicon Valley started if you really
want to talk about it is we'd go to a
party and you I'll be talking about hey
what are you doing to kind of start up
what couldn't engineer it like Oh Atari
you're working out are you he got a job
and everybody get hired right threw a
party to Atari and then they said hey
you doing games and all that so all
these people were talking and swapping
ideas about their startups and this and
that and were you gonna get jobs and all
the parties and ways everything funerals
it was always tech talk among people in
the industry it was very informal back
then some things haven't changed is
still that talk yeah and they were crazy
they were a little crazy so you had you
had the NASA crowd right which is very
like boots on the ground I mean straight
but then lols guys remember sci-fi fans
yeah they so they loved lame when Star
Wars came out and you know Star Trek I
mean a lot of the engineers here are
like a grown-up boys their Trek and Star
Wars out here and in their individual
games in Atari and everything a blast
right after work because where it was so
serious right you couldn't screw up in a
NASA project or a Pentagon project right
lockdown couldn't talk top-secret G
right
I mean you couldn't talk about your work
outside of companies so when you talk
about Atari games yeah because everybody
can do it right so I think there was
kind of this split between serious
military NASA and in the gaming world
and the gaming world was free it was
open consumer and it was the craziest
literally all the hippies and all that
right came down and it was you know the
block parties weren't you know grass
well okay pot and rock and roll right
back in the 70s
so I remember the first parties that the
San Francisco craft so in their books
John Markoff wrote about you know what
the Dormouse knew about the influence of
the Summer of Love and a hippies on
Silicon Valley yeah because remember
back then computing was big iron IBM
right yeah and the PC was the rebel so
it was okay it was Darth Vader versus
the Jedi and all the PC has viewed
themselves as the Jedi battling this big
gigantic thing which was used to design
nuclear bombs and it's important to
Vietnam war so there was a double thing
going on there which is not only
personal computing for a year in your
own stuff but because pcs was about
personal freedom whereas the big
mainframes are used for designing
nuclear bombs it you Lawrence Livermore
and sending our guys off to get killed
in Vietnam so it was split world that's
why when when I remember the PC came on
it was a rebellious statement it was
like protesting the Vietnam War because
you weren't controlled by government
right it wasn't used for killing and if
he did the killing people are off and
this is kind of the dichotomies are
still even happening today
tech companies workers that are saying
or what we build will not be used for
military purposes right yeah so Wow but
see the thing going on there is that
there's still going on always well as
long as we have a large military but um
they say well these games are violent
killing but that's really if you think
about it it's kind of like releasing
pressure because the Cystic game it's
not you know most of the time it doesn't
hurt anybody it's just imagination right
whereas in the real world you're
actually killing real people when drones
in your military so it's not
make-believe there yeah so people don't
talk about that they talk about the
violence in games but they don't talk
about the violence yeah yeah the trust
issues that are there first principle
the first principle thing is that we
have trust issues across the planet I'm
and that's why we have the massive
military budgets all right so so all the
tech industries emerged from militaries
and then not just the US we just have
the largest budget that's all the
largest military budget but all the
nations around the world and military
usually funds technical budgets and
insecurity is important I'm not I'm not
knocking
security I you know we need Amin 9/11 is
a good example we need to have security
otherwise it's like a city without
police it's total anarchy it's not a
safe place well if we learned how to
behave yourself right that's right right
yeah if we can just evolve a little bit
right so but I mean it so there's you
could have well I'd say it citizens but
the danger without police you have
village of vigilantes and then you know
where that one goes right it goes the
wrong way so that's right you have to
have you have to have democratic
democratically elected officials for
control of the police just like the
military and so the people can control
it and so it's not some mob country
because we saw that in history and it's
not pretty so I think we that's where
this whole issue about trust and
governance is very important and I'm I'm
a policy wonk I've said political
science in the use of power and all and
so are you yes do you have faith in
artificial intelligence - it's to govern
us as elected officials which as we can
Oh see it's obvious that it's it's a
it's a system that's gone amuck haywire
you know how can we follow the lead of
our government if we do that we're we're
liars cheats and thieves okay
so AI is a tool or a weapon like any a
nuclear bomb or a gun okay can be used
for the good or evil the danger is if
you have unrestricted use of nuclear
bombs and guns yeah it's a problem and
that's where we are where they are right
now it's not regulated at all from a
policy point of view we don't even know
what we're using it for us that's the
dangerous part so I think that not
nuclear weapons or gun control we need
to start saying this is very dangerous
potentially dangerous so we need to have
some governor's from rules ethics to
guide it because we know right off the
bat
AI automatically embeds all the social
biases and stereotyping in society
because programmers by default are going
to be biased right so the big argument
I've heard with an african-american
community is that it's always biased
toward white people or men not woman
because the programmers tend to be in
that group so the AI just reflects the
society right now so we have to be aware
that right muscle a is really biased
this stereotype I mean I wouldn't
frankly trust it because it's so biased
in other words if you're a human being
saying what AI machines telling you
you would be basically ostracized from
society because it's it's reflecting all
the biases that are in the society would
no overview let's let's let's do a quick
on the last couple minutes yes I think
we're all pointing to the same thing in
the sense of we are our family values
didn't scale our social fabric didn't
scale for like inclusive fitness over
time right and so we we entered into
like a very self dealing era and - yeah
and so and so I think it all points to
this kind of the same thing is that if
we if our family value scaled over time
our social fabric there ended up being
really robust across the civilization
across the whole world we wouldn't need
massive military budgets we wouldn't
need right the the systems that we have
today that are that in many ways are not
representing all people and we can have
more reliance on the tools that we build
like artificial intelligence to help us
out
so let's um let's go because this is
City okay yeah yeah let's keep going
it's a city so we're talking about the
evolution of Silicon Valley then you
ended up also doing the market research
in the semiconductor space in the 80s
yes okay and then also internet
corporate consulting in the 90s actually
advising over 900 tech companies
worldwide right that's crazy okay and so
what was like what was going on around
that time worldwide with the tech boom
well then we saw the rise of Japan
during the 80s with the Japan threat
challenged us and then right after that
Taiwan came on and in before Tigers and
in China and India in that order so we
saw a shift when I started at across the
early 80s the industry is focused on the
Atlantic us and
the Europeans in five to seven years
it's shifted to Asia the book yeah it
was the center of gravity just moved
over no for example the memory chips
the Japanese went from 32% mark sharing
in this middle of eight 1981 to seventy
percent in eighteen months
yeah what fast they're back so that's
why I am be National said only the
paranoid survive because he almost got
put out of business by the Japanese
memory ship companies right so this
shift happened really fast during the
80s from Atlantic to the Pacific and
that was before China and then you have
now the expansion with China and India
so it's moving faster even in that
direction now because India has a
surplus of tech people for example so
it's going to be if you think we've seen
acceleration you haven't seen anything
yet when two billion people come on
India and China yeah oh yeah and most of
them are pretty smart intrinsically
samuli and yeah okay yeah no Road
initiative Africa coming online as well
yeah even without the government just
two billion people okay
so let's say the Chinese government was
like the u.s. come said we'd do whatever
you want that wants we live and eat like
the United States here we would be
totally overwhelmed by Chinese and
Indian technology overnight because you
know there's so many smart people there
now in there tech-savvy
so people are thinking in the past so
this and then the challenge is going to
be one they can't live like Americans
otherwise they'll just burn up the earth
overnight because you know the carbon
emissions from the US per person is 5%
of the population in 25% of the energy
consumption right right yeah
on the other hand and status if Pia if
the rest of these two two billion
want to start consuming and it's not
gonna work so yeah this one now on the
other net opportunity so yeah if I would
argue now we're at the end of one cycle
but we know like PCs and you know like
Silicon Valley as we know it now it's
over people don't realize it where do
you think we're going from there okay
pieces so it's called the fossil fuel
era which was the 20th century mmm-hmm
it was a boon it was a being it's over
people don't realize it's already over
and what's coming is renewable or
cyclical Society because we can't keep
doing fossil fuels and the growth
opportunities and technology and
everything is going to be renewable
cyclical green so 21st century is it's
going to be green all green all green
renewables everything but it's going to
move really fast and people think it's
gonna take 25-30 years the Chinese and
Indians are moving in real-time
they're gonna move in real time with the
technologies the AI OBR everything real
time do you think that has also to do
with their strategy of of not having a
political gridlock of two parties versus
their more greater agility with moving
with the government yes sir you know
this compared China which is highly
centralized control versus India which
is kind of a otic I yeah it's in terms
of public infrastructure yes China is
quote an easier model because you know
you government decides and there's no
such thing as eminent domain is take you
out and then put it in and it's done
right no citizen protest no opposition
okay which is scary too right but that's
the Chinese approach yeah I caught we
caught the bulldozer approaching the
other approach which is is the Cathedral
in the bizarre concept so if China is a
cathedral which is centrally controlled
then the bazaar which is like India
which is more like a free going
democracy with a lot of arguing and all
can work but it tends to work there in
software or notice but in infrastructure
- India is terrible in terms of its way
behind China in terms of roads and
highways and bullet trains and
everything so um I'll guess our does
what it enables looking so the bazaar is
better for capitalism okay it's
individually based there's very little
government control or you know at least
in a so a pure bazaar would be a free
capitalism unrestrained okay whereas the
Chinese model is government controlled
its socialist communist where government
controls everything the trade-off is you
get really you get bullet trains you get
all the free and all the nice buildings
and everything you're advanced and the
trade offices you don't have control
there's no citizen input and the
government could make the wrong
decisions like ghost cities oh yeah that
yeah because there's no input you know
so that's the downside of that on the
other hand you have the India model
which is more free going and Bazaar
people do they want it's really good in
software development better than China
because it's not restricted and more
free flows it internationally that the
problem there is the under invest in
public infrastructure like roads and
highways interesting so you know okay
there's trade-offs from both of now the
ideal world okay anyway Harlem would be
a democracy like India more which but
with the discipline of the Chinese and
in public infrastructure we always know
that so that yeah to find though good in
the private public-private partnership
so in people aren't ideology say talk
about capitalism post capitalism you
know income in communism really if you
look at on a pragmatic level in urban
planning though
it's public private so capitalism tends
to be private driven in business
individual decisions to try it
consumers to drive decisions okay so
it's very free it's really fast you
create a lot of wealth but unrestricted
you have a mess we call externalities
pollution yeah yes it's a problem yeah
the public model is really good for like
I'm in a minor for building highways and
roads and all that beautiful parks like
Golden Gate Park that wasn't done by
capitalism go and Gate Park was by the
city and so grateful for that foresight
yeah so San Francisco take San Francisco
if we had a capitalist model it would
look like a slum a really bad slum
though I mean the whole thing would be a
mess if because we had the city and they
said we're gonna do certain things like
the procedure for the army and then gyms
it over and then going a park we have I
think we have all these parks and
certain amount of public land we have a
fairly beautiful city despite all the
problems in between okay and you can
argue that like homelessness is a
failure of the system both public
actually our don you everybody thinks is
caused by capitalism it's not
homelessness is the problem is poor
public finance and governance
then I'm the urban planner okay so for
example so and it's not the San
Francisco where does one the worst case
because we have it concentrated and it
is easier to take pictures of movies if
San Francisco downtown then LA where
it's all scattered it makes for better
video but the problem in public finance
is that cities are competing to create
to attract jobs which are revenues and
taxes but they don't like the costs
which are housing because housing
requires schools public services roads
it's all cost so if you look at the Bay
Area Palo Alto Nome down to Peninsula
they all want thousands and thousands of
high-paying jobs they don't build any
housing and that's why we have it
two-hour commute in homelessness if the
Seas were truly interested for every job
or every ten jobs they would hire they
would build one or two apartments or
housing so you wouldn't have to drive
again two hours yeah but see that's a
failure of public finance the cities
decide that not the individuals not
businesses
so so I think that's where you know this
really does come together on an urban
planning way it's it's that we we we
really have to realize that by calling
in to thousands and tens of thousands of
jobs into the the centers that we do
need a massive housing developments to
prevent egregious commutes but also that
that we got to also diversify
potentially ourselves away from mega
cities as well
something about mega cities it's like
just it kind of is concrete jungle ask
and I will end up talking a bit about
that down the line out yeah so
remembered it to bring up though some of
the mega cities yes in a bit you taught
us that a lot of tech was moving from
Atlantic trait Pacific train then in
2000's there was a period for you where
you had seven of your 15 startups got
funding while the average is only one of
the thousand during that time um one one
public audience Inc and that did sound
sound in Android phones right and so
teach us about that time in the 2000s
what was going on in the valley
your company's being funded how you were
how are you how were you managing all of
that as well well I mean after 2000 I
mean well we probably lost a quarter
million people who left town because he
got laid off so I remember people just
leaving town in droves San Francisco was
dead 2001 and I remember 2010 it was
after the 2008 crash you could walk down
Market Street and hardly see people it
was an awesome one into and in 2010 or 9
so after both crashes I was always
walking on San Francisco cuz I was
leaving Santa Cruz at the time but I'd
come to City it was like ghost town was
ghost towns and ghost town and everybody
said well the last person turned the
lights out in San Francisco because
there are no jobs and they did nobody
could see the future they said there is
no future for San Francisco I remember
that and we are all going where's the
future so it was really funny I was
doing a market research for Hitachi Data
Systems on utility computing so I talked
to ATT all the big boys because of the
only people surviving and then I said
hey do you know any
started going in as a little company
called salesforce.com downtown and Mon
market I go what do they do those I know
some kind of weird internet thing so I
walk down I got the media with the CTL
and I walk in and whole ATT datacenter
was empty and I said so where your
servers you go all about one in the
corner it was like this big that's their
server oh okay I said where's your team
he goes oh it's around the corner so I
walked around the corner is a little
round table five engineers programming
and he goes welcome to Salesforce I know
are you kidding so what you guys still
need to assess and we're saying the
software service and he goes you know
servers neon goes we still software
directly after service is it oh I get it
so what's your goal eliminate software I
says if Microsoft goes got it and I
asked I said how many you know customers
have 7500 I know what how do you do that
he goes we should have 15,000 but our
productivity is bents we're gonna double
it 3,000 per engineer Oh got it
so I told all my agent on VC friends I
said this is a really cool company
they're doing SAS what SAS yeah well
whatever it's offering service whatever
that is and then they said Sheridan get
out of here we're not gonna invest in
startups and in an internet cuz that's
the fastest way to lose money okay so
okay now mind you I had seen AOL Yahoo
Google because I worked at Stanford or
earlier nine ten years earlier and I got
excited when I saw al del Yahoo Google
spent all those guys I saw all of them
when you're a couple of guys and they
know I buys VC's right and they know I
saw this tall chip companies so they
know I've seen all the coolest companies
in chip history and Silicon Valley plus
all the internet guys they still didn't
listen
I said now put get invest in Salesforce
they said no Sharon we're not going to
touch it said none of them invested
first round in Salesforce okay yeah
because they said the Internet get out
of here we don't want you invest
so I said okay so I said but you're
missing it because this is the future of
the barium and then you got right
sharing of course so I remember that
goes so anyway the minimizing cloud
compute who would have seen what is sad
yeah what is it yeah and then and then
then I saw these startups because I'm
always looking around and because I've
done a lot of startups they'll say hey
sure what you think of the startup so
what's this one cause it's called
Twitter so what they do is they'll check
it out so I go to her it's tweet 140 I
characters they said I said that's
really cool and they said Sheridan why
do I care what my friend ate for
breakfast I said well if your cereal
company no Sharon get out of here it's
like a total waste the time
I said no think about it you can do
whatever you want like headline it's
like what it sports news whatever he
says children when you see something
serious let us know so all the Angels be
she's passed on the Twitter
and then later a couple of years later I
saw another company called Pinterest and
my woman friends tell because they said
hey Sharon does this cool company all
this woman our honor I said okay what
are they doing he goes
they're pretty post pictures and then he
had nylons and Samsonite okay so it's
cool for this woman right and then they
say hey why don't you create a page on
your victories that means because I come
a guy there's awful woman just so I was
one of the first guys to create a
Pinterest page
yeah and I had a guy stuff right hiking
and all the stuff and surfing and then
all of them hey you're cool and I'm
going to accept this the discussion is
all about nylons and socks all right so
I again I went to my angel and VC
friends I said hey what does this really
cool startup company I got okay what's a
call because I get excited all the time
when I see cool companies and they said
let's go
Pinterest they go so guess what all my
VC friends are all guys of course
they're gonna go hey look dude that's a
girl site like it's just like pictures I
said no no no no no it's really serious
it goes look at dude like you can put
anybody put a foot and you don't get it
woman shop do you understand that's what
they're doing is sharing pictures
it says Sheridan and they all told me
when you see something serious let us
know no yeah
and they all passed and then then after
that happened all through the 2000s
archived foresight and predict the
future like that yeah no but all the
woman are on it all but you could tell
that there was high demand for these
things because woman are all excited
about it
so I I said hey Sharon what's to say
guys it's really simple woman shop any
more questions now people I went to a
social marketing event it was really
kind of fun but one thing is something
in the upwards of like 80% of our buying
decision that's correct so here are the
numbers okay so the US economy's only
maybe 20 trillion dollars 70% is
consumer right so it's 14 trillion
dollars
what percents decided by the American
woman 8080 also eight okay so there
yeah fourteen times eighty percent is
what nine point seven trillion nine
point two trillion fifty-five percent of
the US economy it's decided that woman
no this one song you can kind of see
this with your with your friends is like
it's like when you look at your way that
you're maybe your guy friends are making
what decisions is less so maybe in the
realm of like going to purchase things
right and I think everyone including
women is moving towards experiences as
well rather than even material well men
are more impulsive buyers like Cowboys
they go in there and get what they need
and walk out
woman are like pack hunters so they all
talk they talk they share and they know
that best deals so it's interesting so
this one social marketing woman in Sam
so because you know the difference
between b2b and b2c I said now goes b2b
takes two years to get the sale for the
big companies you know yeah and if your
startup maybe a couple of months okay
Beauty how long for b2c sales instant
okay like how politician right away okay
so the baby boomer woman like 50 euros
average time on to site is seven seconds
and if you don't grab them seven they're
gone and you never come back you have
seven seconds and then what is from
Millennials your seconds to two and a
half seconds Moses quick yeah so they
said and then so here is the question if
you're a a b2c retail guy a CEO a fifty
year old guy what is the odds that
you'll understand what a twenty year old
woman is going to decide in two seconds
zero yeah and then some of they said go
to the shopping malls what percent of
the people are online or are me on the
shops are for a woman I say 80 percent
of the shops what did the men look like
in the malls goes no kind of bored he
goes we call them zombies in the retail
market why cuz they're so out of it they
don't even know what they cuz they're
like you know Saudi so they would always
say what do you what do you think online
would be any different than the shopping
mall yeah now here's the thing though
when when we talk about climate change
now okay remember
fifty-five percent of the consumer
decision decided in seconds by woman
fifty nine and a half ten eleven
trillion dollars and now and look at a
globe right now do you know what that
means if they're all mobile and these
women are deciding in seconds do you
know what that means to any company that
they don't like you could literally sink
a company overnight yeah cuz all the one
talk and they'll be on social media so
the stock could literally go like this
overnight yeah if they don't think they
like you this is another one of the
reasons why there's a lot of power in
though in the woman to woman's control
on decisions on where a trajectory of
our workings a couple quick thoughts is
that you you were giving us you're
giving us some of the some of the
craziness of what was going on with some
of the missed opportunities where people
didn't see back in the 2000s also what
was happening with buying decisions I
mean I I know that what I was mentioning
earlier about megacities this is this
seems to be the designs that were going
towards in the future that we really
want to see more of and that we want to
see less of the concrete jungles that
have so much yes some of also disastrous
trauma embedded in humans that there's
all this type of stuff that we okay
let's let's hit on this quick you also
started the Silicon Valley global
network as well and that was a forum to
promote entrepreneurship via global
collaboration and that has over 50,000
members a sec
no eighty hmm 85,000 members now I
remember I joined in late 2015 yeah it
was just back then it was so much less
and it just keeps growing it's
incredible seeing how that's grown that
links in the bio everyone go check that
out there's a lot of great global
collaboration that's happening in that
global network and then the book is well
the untold stories from a Silicon Valley
insider in the valuation adream what
were the massive failures and grand
slams or those are the ones that you
kind of started looking so what do you
hear the two ones I I feel bad about it
but there are my clients I was doing
emerging technologies at data quests so
I had all these corporate accounts and
then later I did it too but on my own as
a consultant so the biggest failures in
history was Kodak and Dec the equipment
so in the mid 80s
I would go to Rochester and it's a
Sheridan was hot in Silicon Valley tell
us what's the future for codec so all
during 80s like eighty four or five I
did say digital cameras and they said
what I said you know Japan they got
digital cameras so the future codec is
digital photography and they said surely
you don't understand our business and I
said what do you mean because we're a
film company do you understand that
we're not a digital camera company I
said oh no your your analog film
companies today but in the future will
be all digital and it goes like what
percent I said oh maybe 99.9 percent in
the film would be more like you know
rare photos and they said you seriously
think that we're gonna go to digital
cameras like Japanese I said you have no
choice when are you gonna make the move
and they said well how long do we have I
said I'll put this way you have to start
now because they did you a photography
electronics is pretty sophisticated
I told me I'm like film you got to be in
Silicon Valley right so you should
probably set up operation here to do
your chips and all that here and maybe
in collaborate with Japanese and then
but do you have maybe 10 years and if
you don't figure it out and by 1995 it's
over
the game's over in 2000 year bankrupt
damn and they said you sure I said trust
me
then they never listened oh well so I I
knew I actually before went back up I
already knew that 15 years ahead of time
I I was watching it go under I know it's
going you you can't force a horse drink
water yeah so that same thing digital
equipment remember the mini Frank they
were my client emergency equipment no
Digital Equipment Corporation deck deck
yeah
you said Leena corporation some Boston
they had 120,000 employees oh my gosh so
then they were my account the emerging
tech diamond had some masks I used to
fly in there after go into Rochester and
they I would say hey Cheryl what's the
future and I said $10,000 workstations
why that because our million we still
million quarter million dollar million
dollar computers and I said well and now
you do but you don't have a chance
because there's a kid named my Scott
McNealy from Stanford Business School
he just started come across son and
workstation is ten thousand dollars so
that's your competition and they go
Sharon you don't understand us I got
okay what do I understand we're a VM X
machine company I said no that's a
closed system his open and open will be
closed
they said Sheridan we started quarter
million are as I said right now but in
the future you're gonna be at ten
thousand if you want to survive yeah
okay so I said look set up a workstation
to compete with Scott McNealy while you
still have money yeah right
all the 80s seven years later they laid
off when they be shut down they laid off
all hundred twenty thousand people
totally destroyed the computer industry
in Boston right that was my account and
I knew that I warned them all the 80s
both of them Wow but and so you knew you
can't force companies and then later you
know Harvard Business School professor
wrote an acquaintance Christiansen wrote
you know in the disruptive technology in
the 90s
based on those disruptions
so he wrote about a ten years after I
did cuz you know academics have to have
data whereas I was doing forecasting
saying here's what to avoid was he wrote
but here's what well here are the
mistakes in past tense
these examples are important for young
people because we don't necessarily take
it out of our 25 or 35 or even 15 year
old time scale right often enough right
but to understand what Silicon Valley
used to look like these mistakes that
were made how to not repeat these
mistakes how to work towards a global
cohesion we've been looking back on a
big history time scale we always like
trying to get people to think of an
evolution of our species over even all
six million years okay let's hit on the
massive Grand Slams as well right okay
so one was saving Intel so Intel is my
account at data quests the senior VP
reporting to the troika more grove and
you know so you know the Japanese took
out their memory business right so they
were going and so the senior VP called
me and the boss my manager and say guys
I gotta have lunch with you today so
here were in Milpitas and he dropped the
bomb on us he says guys does not go out
of this room you're the only two people
outside there's only six of us in the
world who know the troika me and it -
you do not say a word
we're going under Intel's going under in
six months 46 months were going bankrupt
and I like I like we all choked on our
lunch and then we used for the next hour
and we met three or four weeks in a row
and he's telling us how bad it was
bleeding and and Wall Street didn't know
they were that loss and so Gordon warned
every civil shodhan in gene where the
Asia Japanese immigrant service we knew
the competition right
so they said yeah so what does Dataquest
think and I remember I was guy god it's
pretty depressing so my boss chives to
me cuz what do you think I shouldn't ask
him first
I said well look at they already lost
the memory chip market right so they
should I know it's hard layoffs 70% of
people in a memory department and focus
on micro process because the pcs coming
coming be number one in the world and
process and don't look back hmm I need
my boss said that's what I was thinking
too so so then we told Ron Ron goes okay
what's the verdict from data question
and my boss was sure night in both great
shutdown memory tomorrow focus on
processes and you know what Ron goes are
you sure it goes yeah we think that so
he calls back a couple hours later and
he goes guys we can't do it the troika
says Wall Street will go nuts yeah yeah
then we'll never allow us to do that and
then my boss is famous classic response
was well tell Andy and you know all the
guys there look we think it's a
no-brainer you can shut down 70% of
company tomorrow or the whole company in
six months you don't have a choice and
they go why do you say that goes well
we're putting together the five billion
dollar one megabit dram strategy for
Samsung so if you get past the six
Japanese sounds who's coming
with billions yeah you don't have a
chance
you're already roadkill to double down
on Michael cross so then so then yeah
that's your only chance
so I remember the funny costs Enron goes
wow that's pretty depressing so he goes
back the next morning the call comes in
Iran comes in my boss pulls me
because he goes okay guys I pitched the
guy in the troika and he said data
crisis we don't have a chance
we're going for it we're going from
micro processors don't tell anybody's
away yes so what happened was he goes
loose lips sink ships don't say for two
or three weeks said nothing and then
front-page news man it's just Intel like
and in Wall Street went nuts and all the
reporters are calling us and we pretend
we didn't know anything right and then
for the next year Intel sinan your
microprocessor guys that we coached him
on how to become number one in peace in
microprocessors how did the market
strategy and everything so we did that
and then he turned around so then later
when Ron came into my boss said Ron
congratulations the UN Detroit greatest
tournament business history in United
States
and that's why any grovero only the
paranoid survive because they almost
went under and but so I was really kind
of happy because my boss says hey we
saved Intel not bad huh
and we did we saved them because they
were gonna stay with memories and they
would have been caught in Troy as we
know it would be gone Wow exists you
know what a story tell us the biggest
Grand Slam we've ever had then I was
involved in Nokia's launch an AMD and
all these others like big ones you know
but well we'll have to revisit more of
the Silicon Valley stories with you
again in another session there's so much
good stuff there shared and Wow
Wow it's important to tell these stories
is important um so you wrote several
books a VR series and novels and then
launched launching the 9th 10th 11th
12th companies right now yeah one of
them is one reality which creates me
aren't models of sustainable cities
you've visited Sweden in 2008-2009 and
then you notice that like that really
Sweden and the Nordics care a lot about
these sustainable cities currently
building models for Copenhagen stock
homeland and Malmo yes and so let's sum
this is using the Unreal vr gaming
engine ok and this is taking Copenhagen
from a macro view and my first one so
you're immersing is this like global
city leaders environmentalists anybody
anybody that they want they can wear
virtual reality and see what the future
of Stockholm can look like yeah because
in an or well it'll background er the
company has been using virtuality for 20
years when we had million dollar
machines in hundred thousand headsets
but now we could do it on laptops a
cheap headset same thing because of the
Nvidia chips they're so powerful so what
we do is we use sort of like a Google
does but we don't use Google Earth
because that's you can't control it and
you can't get the data so we have our
own earth which is in their commodity
now the skin in satellite data is
commodity so we have asked in Copenhagen
Malmo port which is a billion dollar
port there
a public agency on behalf of the cities
mammal and Copenhagen to generate
revenues for the city through port
management so it's like Samsa square
report or Long Beach or you know port so
what they did is they wanted to use
virtuality for their marketing initially
in anyone didn't user later for other
purposes so what they were trying to do
is to show the Chinese ship container
companies how how the new port would
look because what happened was there was
a there's a boom in could tour ISM and
they were mixing the tourist ships with
the container ships in the port which is
really crazy so they are thinking why
don't we just bring the tourists right
into town and then move and open up a
new port to the south just for the
containers because they don't need to be
in the middle of town in this separate -
- so they wanted to visualize it so what
they had and Copenhagen
you know let's pull let's pull back up
the first one again so they have all the
the report actually had all the
satellite data they had all the GIS data
they had they don't show it here but
they had all the utility - they had the
planes coming in out of the planes the
trucks the trains the sewer the water
everything and so we can visualize all
that all over that being visual alright
because the Copenhagen mobile port
controls not only the airport but all
urban development on 50 miles Denmark
and the Sweden side both sides
everything housing everything so you do
not you bring up a critical point which
is just that when we look at this from
the sky we're not thinking about all the
infrastructures underneath of the ground
yep plumbing the electrical all that
type of stuff so then we actually built
underground so we go underneath
Copenhagen and we can see and water and
sewage going through the pipes in VR
that's pretty cool yeah cuz they had the
data now if you it's stored data but
because whether we can accelerate the
flow but if you have real-time data then
you could see it in real time you just a
few sensors it's just you know hooking
it up so you can do both and then this
is the macro level so this what we do is
we take the static images which is and
then we had a
so we took our own drone like a little
with an iPad and then a little drone and
we flew over Copenhagen port we captured
the whole port yeah with higher
resolution with our drone our own
cameras we did it in one hour and we
just overlay it over the because of the
satellite imagery which does be fuzzier
because it's shot you know - so high up
so you're overlaying over the light with
drone imagery for Google cuz you know
it's we get high risk cameras that
Google does when you drive down the
street or you do a drone and you overlay
otherwise what happens is all your walls
are kind of fuzzy yeah my god in the
streets of fuzzy gosh when do we scan it
in madrone is super clear yeah and it's
like bener so we do that we overlay and
that gives us the static world the
existing world and then the fun starts
okay so then we start adding planes cars
trains okay so we could show we could
add any moving object because remember
we're using a gaming agent and all our
guys are gamers yes so they think
buildings are boring because they're
static whereas gamers like action so
they like the trains cars planes clouds
now we can do storms flooding whatever
you want so you can simulate what it's
like to have a storm and then where the
water runoff goes we do that all the
time so one of the things we did was see
rise so we took Cove a port you can
stand you could zoom down to any block
and then we run it one foot per second
and we put copening at under 40 feet of
water in 40 seconds see you're standing
you're watching the whole city disappear
for any angle from any angle it's kind
of it's really depressing when you see
it because it's scary to watch so you're
building the VR models all the way down
to the street level as well right from
the macro and then we go all the way
down to the street yes as well as the
guts underneath the ground can we have
done the ground - from the city because
we have the GIS data and all their
infrastructure there they supplied it to
us
the city is supplied it and the port and
they want this because they want to know
how to build their future so yeah they
could do anything they want so for
example now
have this then we we could design and
I'll show you in the next pictures but
we design new communities and everything
and then here's what we do so in loaned
across the strait the Europeans are
putting two synchrotrons there's not no
housing so we're adding ooh 10,000
housing for 10,000 people of researchers
okay
and nobody international research coming
in and then there's a light rail because
they don't want to rely on cars to go to
the research park yeah so you can see
this is how we use VR so all the black
areas all existing satellite data for
the existing area and then we have any
open fields now we're starting to play
it's like a Legos the Warrens is your
added we're adding new the Newtown urban
design at the macro level so we could
what we want to do is layout to see how
everything fits at the macro level first
yeah all right and then you know where
the Train should go so we kind of play
around with urban planning we do this
all the time she'd the housing be over
here the intrigue this way this way
how will the parking stores shops
everything you know we kind of lay out
and it takes a while to figure out the
right layout yes you know where the
shopping malls this net so you reduce
the traffic and carbon and everything
right so that's we do at the macro level
then we then we go to the micro level
which is even closer okay and that's the
next video okay so then now the orange
buildings now we take and we just give
the orange boxes to the architects
uh-huh yeah got it and then the same
orange buildings that are gonna be
coming up right this is this is that
same light rail you were just showing us
so the last image where these are the
new housing developments for the
researchers right so what happens if
this is the next step so we gave the
orange boxes and they say okay it's
roughly here but it's not even designed
and then the architects there's a sign
for that block they take it and then
they start doing your thing in AutoCAD
the CAD models so they designer on they
do inside outside with the BIM models
and then we just drop them right in oh
you just drop them right in from there
into the VR model we just drop it right
in it's that easy
oh we just drop right in off the our
model yeah we drop it in so and in many
of the via well many of the
architectural firms in a bear like
insulin all are starting with BIM models
which are real popular for the inside of
the building but now they're using their
arm because you could do the street
scenes and everything okay and the other
thing about virtuality is that we could
do dynamic models action in everything
avatars every night storms you can't do
that with dim dim beam is good for
static buildings buildings is that sure
but so then we take the BIM as like the
template okay so if you say here's the
building it's done by an architecture
firm then what we can do is fly from
outer space if we had the model we could
go right into the floor go onto the
elevator to go up to the third floor go
up and turn on the lights turn open the
kitchen door open the refrigerator door
we have the stereo sound going on we've
got the lights we have the time tracking
for any day of the year in history whoa
yeah and then what we do is we then the
fun starts for us because that's a
static so what we do is we start adding
to cool sound design yeah we are plants
we drop the avatars in so you walk in
there and maybe they have a party going
on we have all of these avatars they're
all like dancing having fun talking and
then with AI we could train the avatars
so you could do whatever you want so
that's more the gaming element which is
if you look at cities this place and
people yes virtuality for architects is
mostly place buildings and that's
interesting for us it's more about
people which is people buildings
landscaping because we do all the lens
yeah yeah and then and then disasters
weather let's let's hit that one in a
moment so we're going from the right
we're going from macro views of future
cities all from drone data plus
satellite data
I'm also into the data that you got from
the cities on their infrastructures that
are below the ground as well all the way
from macro into Street View views and on
the street view views you can go all the
way into just plop the CAD designs and
settings right into the VR of situation
and you go into the buildings see ya and
so and so this is interesting because as
you make developments for new
researchers that are coming in you have
to make a show how you want the blocks
arranged where you want the businesses
that type stuff the transit systems then
it can take them even a step further
it's like well here's what your
apartment is going to look like you can
go in your bed we sell furniture too we
can drop for your job furniture in show
the other social aspect some other
avatars in there here's the other
researchers and avatars from other
places in the world this is what this
experience is gonna be like who are you
and then have the sound design like you
said all those other aspects right way
and then just on this last part you just
said about disaster relief so that if
things happen like massive storms or or
or any type of other earthquake or you
know tornados or disasters that it's
easy for you to be able to simulate what
them do they like to the city right okay
yes so for example on this one we did a
hurricane like if you were in Miami and
we had the hurricane and you can just
moderate so 50 100 150 200 miles an hour
and you just ramped it up and then you
could say which directions are wind
coming in say say from this direction
and you put in and then what's scary and
watch is when it hits about 170 to 200
miles an hour the trees start tipping in
all the buildings in the real start
tearing off and flying all over the
place because you know we're it's
they're based on the physics engine
they're not real really good yeah
so it's very realistic it's based on
real physics it's not make-believe and
then you could add atmospheric models to
that to make it even better so but we
simulated that we did the sea rise wine
we did flooding so we could have like a
big flood take it out with ten foot
waves coming through there if you want
yeah we do that we have fires we can't
explosions because remember they're
gamers
yes sir game gamers love
so we have that's where the gamers start
bringing it to life so this is for
disaster preparedness planning so for
example if the police fire and everybody
wants to see what might happen like the
ghost fire what might happen if a
building catches on fire what do we need
to do bring our assets and our teams and
your trucks and all and they could
simulate the whole thing so for example
if there's a fire we could say okay we
could then bring in that fire chief with
his VR just like Legos he just moves his
trucks around or her trucks around and
then they could simulate the fire so
they could do a firefighting simulation
yeah and we do that so then this say
okay here's or we have we drop some foam
on top we had firefighters they go into
the building with their virtual fire
hose and you're putting out the fire
right there yeah yeah so we could
simulate the whole fire in the
firefighting and the training purposes
for it yeah and that's the real use of
the ours for them is training and it's
but multi-agency so we have to fire
please water medica everybody can look
at it together and then they could
replay it to say and then we want to do
contest so for example if a fire happens
the winners save all the lives and the
least damage the losers lose 200 people
and the building goes up
so your gamify it by saying how many
lies and how much property can you say
that's the game so who remembers a
gaming engine and for example many of
these the gaming developers were coming
out of the mostly come out of unity
because that's where ninety-eight
percent of gamers developers are now but
they're moving to Unreal - and we could
also do it unity either way but they are
now moving into Enterprise in cities and
the differences in the game world it's
nice but it's Fantasyland it's just all
make-believe well we're doing this is
for real these cities are actually
coming up to the c-suite we do and so
the plan is to go from the Nordics and
continue doing City future of city
developments with governments private
organizations like these types of things
around the world right okay and in the
hope is is that when you have VR models
of future of cities that then the cities
that are built are more intelligent
they're smarter cities they're more
sustainable cities right they give
people a more immersive experience into
what it looks like to be living there
nice types of things so then one of the
problems for public hearings is they
usually have the medians at 2:00 in the
afternoon and nobody can because they're
a 10 because they're going to work what
I think the future is is that you could
put the models online and then at home
every citizen or anybody in the world
could go walk around the community and
see what's proposed and then leave and
your post-it notes like comments
something that comments and I think
that's where citizen participation the
future is gonna be more online because
you can't go to the meetings but in VR
you could be anywhere and just like walk
around in it and then you don't need a
VR headset
what's Smith so we do most of our your
modeling right on the computer on a tap
we did mostly tablets yeah and laptops
VR just immerses you into it but you can
see the same stuff on a 2d yes the same
3d assets yeah the only difference is
it's like the looking at San Francisco
from a bus when you're
flat-panel cuz you can't go through the
window but when you're in the are your
there's no bus you're just walking
around in it okay right okay yeah it's
interesting on the on people being able
to be engaged on on a city future of
cities development basis yeah um yeah
that's this is Wow Wow so much stuff and
that was men also includes even all the
way down to the micro level which you
guys are doing some of the medical
actually was a Nobel Prize intensity and
rhythms in 217 for the work of one
reality going down to the medical level
the cellular level so there's a lot of
potential future with what know with
what yeah with in medicine for virtual
reality and what you guys are doing with
one reality which is great um yeah mega
cities are some I'm I'm gonna be there's
some things about mega cities that I
hope they get designed more sustainably
in the furniture because there's
millions and millions of people that are
moving into them across the world yeah
sure Dan let's um just quick two
questions on the way out do you think
we're in a simulation yes we are we're
in a simulation I'm well we're already
doing it in their minds right think
about it we're simulating our brains our
computers in a sense so we're all
simulating already
so it were cameras if you think about it
but we're a bio camera so that's one and
if you're really religious I would argue
you could say and here's going to way I
look at it as you can say if God or the
energy or whatever this divine energy is
controlling the universe then that
whatever force it is is simulating
whatever's going on here at a macro
level and then what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world in
terms of I think it's science and the
way we act is art it's all art mm-hmm
because when we look at the Nobel Prize
when we look at beautiful cities the
Stars is like art this is pure art and
you know it's it's it's um so I think
ultimately that's really what all this
BR is all about yeah in uh yeah it's a
way of looking at the world in a fresh
way because remember we're we're
creating the world there yeah so ii you
know if you really think about it each
of us will be artists creating the
future world so the question is what
kind of future cities and worlds do we
want to create yes yes yes it's up to us
it's not that the ours is a tool a is a
tool it's beautifully said civilization
is art and then can we do things like
use these tools to be able to make the
future cities that we want to live to
make the art better and have less
mistakes and a more beautiful cities and
you know nicer places where you like
hanging out with friends and good music
and food I mean come on you know and I
think I kind of harken back to the good
part of the summer of love or the
festival Street vessels and all that all
the really great things you could
simulate all this envy are like anything
you want yeah so why not do it there's
gonna be a lot more to unpack with you
when we got to do so more Silicon Valley
history more global tech history
development as well as more on the VR
has one reality keeps developing cherdon
thank you so much okay with the show for
your time
really appreciate it yeah very
enlightening thank you thanks for coming
on thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode get talking more about
future cities with your family your
friends people online on social media
get talking more about the tech
revolution that we've had in
civilization check out the links in the
bio to one reality as well as Sheridan's
book Silicon Valley global network as
well as there are more one reality VR
demos that link is below as well thank
you to Ronnie Vargas for producing and
directly we greatly appreciate it and
also support the artisanal entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe in support simulation our
links are below help us sustain grow and
prosper and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dream since the
world thank you so much for tuning in we
will see you soon peace ok great that
was nice
[Music]
[Music]